if you know me you know that I'm from
Pittsburgh and I'm a huge football fan
and I'm so pumped about the new seasons
kicking off now I wanted to try
something to give my favorite team an
edge this year so I'm partnering with
Google to show you how their new
supercharged search engine will make
looking for answers to any football
related question that much smarter and
simpler and better yet it can be done
all within the handy new Google app
first you can open the app tap the icon
in the top left corner and toggle on the
option to try out generative AI
experience and search then you can start
using it immediately now I'm going to
search for something that's been on my
mind the last couple of weeks since
kickoff what are common football game
day superstitions after I type it in I
see an AI powered snapshot links to
learn more as well as additional content
from across the web all in one handy
place saving me from scrolling through
pages of results thank you to the Google
app and the new way to use Google search
keep it in mind this football season and
let me know in the comments if you've
had a chance to try it out yet